pour
[Musique]
selon une étude choc publié en août
dernier la planète approche d'un point
de rupture
plusieurs des systèmes régulateurs du
climat risque de basculer d'ici quelques
décennies causant un emballement
climatique
menant à des températures encore plus
élevé l'un de ses importants systèmes et
juste à nos portes
c'est un vaste courant océanique ce
courant appelé la circulation méridienne
de retournement de l'atlantique nord
formule boucle son segment le plus connu
et le golf tués il conduit les eaux du
golfe du mexique vers le nord ses eaux
chaudes sont particulièrement salée car
elles sont soumises à davantage
d'évaporation
elle voyage en surface et lorsqu'elles
arrivent au nord elle se refroidisse et
par le fait même s'alourdisse à cause de
leur salinité
elles sont plus lourdes que les
authentiques résultat elles plongent
dans les profondeurs
ce puissant mouvement hydrique et moteur
de la boucle nord atlantique
ce système agit comme un calorifère il
réchauffe le rap et fait partie d'un
circuit plus vaste mondiale or depuis
des années les modèles climatiques
prédisent que cet équilibre fin de
température salinité est en péril et que
ce moteur risque de s'affaiblir
les glaces de l'arctique et du groenland
fondent plus rapidement que les
prédictions les plus pessimistes
elle déverse chaque année des millions
de tonnes d'eau douce dans l'atlantique
assez pour diluer les eaux salines
entraver la formation d'odense
et détraqué le moteur mais comment
savoir si dans les océans ce
ralentissement a déjà débuté
mesurer l'état de ces gigantesques
système océanique est complexe et
historiquement des mesures directes sont
rares les meilleurs enregistrements
proviennent de ces instruments 22
censeurs amarré au fond de l'océan
atlantique de la floride jusqu'en
afrique
il traque le débit et la température du
courant c'est le réseau rapide mais il
n'est là que depuis 2004
c'est peu il révèle un courant haut
débit très variable et pour l'instant
ralentissement dix fois plus importants
qu'estimé par les modèles ces
instruments ne nous offrait qu'un aperçu
locale de ce qui est en train de se
passer dans l'océan atlantique
de nouvelles observations change la
donne
partout sur la planète
les températures dépassent les moyennes
historiques
sauf au dessus du moteur de la boucle
océanique en 2015 alors qu'on
enregistrait des chaleurs record ici on
mesurait un froid record
plusieurs chercheurs croient que cette
anomalie fournit une preuve convaincante
du ralentissement de la boucle océanique
ils ont disséqué cette anomalie en
analysant les modèles climatiques
cette maj froide frais causés par le
ralentissement de la boucle océanique
qui convoie 20% moins de chaleur vers le
nord qu'il ya une décennie
les chercheurs observent aussi un
réchauffement de la côte est américaine
ensemble ces deux phénomènes forme une
signature d'un ralentissement des cours
en servant des températures passées à la
surface de la mer
les chercheurs ont ensuite reconstruit
d'histoire du secours à résultats il
observe à l'affaiblissement de 15%
depuis les années 50
la préoccupation des scientifiques est
aussi de savoir quelle part de ce
ralentissement est causée par du bain
pour comprendre le passé de ce courant
les chercheurs doivent avoir recours à
d'autres indices indirectes comme
l'analyse de croissance des coraux
aussi l'étude des sédiments du plancher
océanique a permis de reculer de deux
millénaires et de retracer la vitesse
des courants profonds longeant
l'amérique
les derniers doutes se dissipe la preuve
sera fermé la boucle c'est annick
s'affaiblit de manière naturelle depuis
1600 ans et sont des trains s'accélère
depuis l'ère industrielle et atteint son
point le plus faible aujourd'hui
ce déclin aura des conséquences sur le
climat européen et accélérera
l'innovation du niveau marin sur les
côtes de l'amérique du nord
il pourrait aussi causer un déplacement
vers le sud de la ceinture depuis
tropicale et au réchauffement de l'océan
antarctique
pire encore plusieurs indices laissent
croire que ce courant océanique pourrait
soudainement s'effondrer si son débit
ralenti en deçà d'un seuil critique en
niant les conditions de ce point de
bascule
chose certaine plus la planète se
réchauffe plus les risques sont
importants
le rapport du giec publié il ya quelques
semaines rappelle qu'il est possible de
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré à
condition de faire des changements
profonds sans précédent et rapide un
demi degré de plus en ra des
répercussions majeures sur la planète
ces mécanismes régulateurs et sur le
vivant